[Música]
recuerden comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con nuestro numeral directo
américa efe 24 estaremos al tanto de sus
comentarios
comienza entonces directo américa con
noticias de la alta comisionada de la
onu para los derechos humanos michelle
bachelet quien publicó el esperado
informe sobre su visita a la región de
xinjiang en mayo en china y determinó
que se han cometido graves violaciones
de derechos humanos contra la minoría
musulmana uigur el contexto de lo que el
gobierno chino califica como operaciones
destinadas a combatir el extremismo se
estima que más de un millón de augures
se encuentran detenidos en llamados
campos de reeducación bachelet quien
deja hoy el cargo dice que la detención
arbitraria y discriminatoria de beijing
hacia esta población puede constituir
crímenes de lesa humanidad la misión de
china ante la onu criticó el informe y
dijo que se basó en desinformación y
mentiras fabricadas por fuerzas anti
chinas previamente se había puesto a su
publicación argumentando que las
denuncias en xinjiang son una mentira
destinada a socavar la estabilidad y el
desarrollo de su país
en conclusión las descripciones de las
detenciones en el período comprendido
entre 2017 y 2019 recopilados por la
alta comisionada para los derechos
humanos estuvieron marcados por patrones
de tortura u otras formas de trato cruel
tratos o penas inhumanas o degradantes
otras violaciones de los derechos de las
personas privados de su libertad de ser
tratados humanamente y con dignidad así
como violaciones de los derechos a la
salud también se denunciaron casos de
violencia sexual y de género
pasamos a ucrania a un grupo de
inspectores nucleares del organismo
internacional de energía atómica llegó a
sap orilla encabezado por su director
rafael grossi se espera que el equipo
pase la noche en la ciudad antes de
visitar la planta ocupada por rusia y
supervisar los daños causados por los
ataques que han suscitado temores de un
eventual accidente radioactivo el
ministro de energía de ucrania afirmó
que la misión de la oea a la central es
un paso hasta hacia la desocupación y
desmilitarización del lugar más detalles
en el siguiente informe
después de semanas de discusiones
diplomáticas y logísticas un equipo de
expertos del organismo internacional de
energía atómica ha llegado finalmente a
sap orilla la ciudad del sur de ucrania
alberga la mayor central nuclear de
europa un lugar que ha sido objeto de
ataques de ambos bandos desde que rusia
invadió el país a principios de este año
el principal temor por supuesto es un
accidente nuclear que agravaría un
conflicto ya desastroso evitar un
incidente en la central es lo que espera
el equipo del oiea
y creo que es muy importante establecer
con toda claridad que mi misión es una
misión técnica es una misión que busca
prevenir un accidente nuclear y
preservar esta importante central
nuclear más grande de europa guns
pero si los expertos serán capaces de
lograr sus objetivos es una incógnita en
las últimas 24 horas los funcionarios
locales controlados por moscú afirmaron
que las tropas ucranianas lanzaron
ataques con drones contra el edificio
administrativo y el centro de
entrenamiento de la planta ucrania por
su parte acusó a los rusos de bombardear
las carreteras de acceso a la planta
también está en duda la duración del
viaje el organismo internacional de
control nuclear espera establecer una
misión permanente en la planta lo que
sólo podría ocurrir si cesan los
combates en los alrededores mientras
tanto ucrania ha dejado claro que quiere
que la misión de la agencia conduzca a
una retirada completa de las tropas
rusas
los ministros de asuntos exteriores de
la unión europea respaldaron suspender
el acuerdo de facilitación de visados a
todos los ciudadanos rusos algo que
dificulta su estancia como turistas en
la unión europea de cara al futuro más
en el siguiente informe
un visado que será más caro y más
difícil de obtener esa es la nueva
realidad para los ciudadanos rusos que
quieran entrar en la unión europea los
ministros de asuntos exteriores de los
27 estados miembros acordaron el
miércoles en fraga poner fin al régimen
de visa relajada para los rusos vigente
desde 2007
esto significa que se reducirá
significativamente el número de nuevas
visas expedidas por los estados miembros
de la unión europea mandar stage
el proceso será más difícil y más largo
y por consiguiente el número de nuevas
visas se verán sustancialmente reducida
y sustancial y medios
será una suspensión del régimen actual
pero no una prohibición total de visados
para todos los rusos como pedían polonia
y los tres países bálticos sólo se
seguirá impidiendo viajar a europa a los
allegados al kremlin objetivo desde el
inicio de la guerra en ucrania para
algunos estas nuevas medidas no son
suficientes
no se trata de un castigo se trata
básicamente de plantearse la cuestión de
si el derecho a pasar un tiempo de ocio
en la unión europea es un derecho humano
y no lo creo es un privilegio y los
países suelen tener que ganarse este
tipo de privilegios
junto a lituania polonia letonia y
estonia están considerando la
posibilidad de prohibir completamente el
paso de rusos por sus fronteras pero
varios países sobre todo alemania han
argumentado que una prohibición total
penalizaría a los disidentes y a todos
los rusos que quieran huir de su país
más de un millón de ciudadanos rusos han
entrado en la unión europea desde el
inicio de la invasión en ucrania la
mayoría de ellos a través de finlandia y
estonia
vamos a reino unido porque en londres se
llevó a cabo el último acto de campaña
del partido conservador en la carrera
para elegir a la persona que sustituirá
a boris johnson frente al gobierno
británico la secretaria de exteriores
listos y el ex ministro de finanzas-
reich es una que se disputará en la
votación ambos estuvieron presentes en
el acto el próximo lunes 5 de septiembre
se conocerán los resultados oficiales
los detalles con nuestra corresponsal en
londres louis ha pulido
tras seis semanas de campaña por todo el
reino unido- los candidatos que esperan
suceder a boris johnson risas unac y
listas siguen escuchando el mismo clamor
hay que atender con urgencia la crisis
en el costo de vida la inflación que
está disparada y también la crisis de la
energía los dos candidatos coincidieron
esta noche en que se debe atender está
urgentemente pero justamente dejaron en
evidencia que tienen distintas visiones
sobre cómo manejar la economía y esto es
radica en subir o bajar los impuestos
mientras que ellis tras la favorita para
hacer la nueva primera ministra y actual
secretaria de exteriores asegura que
reversar a los impuestos que subieron en
abril y que no crearán nuevos risas una
quien fuera hasta hace unas semanas el
ministro de finanzas británico ha dicho
que no los bajara y que esto podría ser
posible en el futuro sólo cuando la
inflación esté controlada lo cierto es
que los integrantes del partido
conservador unas 200.000 personas la
última palabra votarán hasta el próximo
2 de septiembre el anuncio sobre el
quién es el primer ministro será este
lunes y el martes 6 de septiembre la
reina isabel por primera vez en la
historia recibirá en el castillo de
balmoral en escocia al saliente primer
ministro y al nuevo primer ministro esto
por problemas de movilidad que la
monarca británica la jefe de estado está
experimentando desde hace varios meses
y se abre un nuevo capítulo en el caso
del allanamiento de las residencias de
donald trump según el departamento de
justicia de eeuu documentos
confidenciales encontrados en mara lago
fueron probablemente ocultados y
eliminados como parte de los esfuerzos
para obstruir una investigación federal
en contra del ex presidente tram fue
acusado de haber manipulado material
clasificado de forma incorrecta para
analizar este tema saludamos en san juan
puerto rico a luis pabón roca él es
abogado y analista político señor pavón
bienvenido a directo américa adhesión
nocturna que nos dice la forma en la que
ha avanzado la investigación a qué
escenarios judiciales se podría
enfrentar trump ahora que se habla de
una presunta obstrucción a la justicia
muy buena noche antes que todo y gracias
por el progreso de estar aquí pues mira
los frentes de guerra de trops son
varios no por qué va ha llamado la
atención ahora mismo a las noticias
porque se está disputando por parte de
él en un proyecto civil lo que aparenta
hacer una acción criminal que pretende
llevar el departamento de justicia y la
discusión es si estuvo bien o no su
allanamiento hay que ponerlo en contexto
eeuu no está acostumbrado a que sus
primeros mandatarios sean encausados
criminalmente esto tal vez en
latinoamérica pasa con alguna frecuencia
en eeuu no habría que remontarse a nixon
que no hubo un proceso criminal pero
renunció ante la inminente
posibilidades que sucedieron aquí hay un
estado georgia está planteando y sus
criminales en nueva york' está haciendo
investigaciones el principal oficial de
financiero de las empresas trump se
declaró culpable hace una semana por lo
tanto son muchos los frentes
pero hay un frente más amplio que es el
político y ahí es donde yo creo que esto
es importante porque hay unas elecciones
de medio término ahora en noviembre
ahora los republicanos han comparado el
caso de tron con el de los correos de
hillary clinton que recordemos uso su
servidor privado para manejar
información de estado y cuestionan que
con ella no ocurre absolutamente nada
pueden realmente compararse estos dos
casos no no no no se pueden comparar
porque lo que pasa es que trump
literalmente se llevó documentos que
claro todavía no estamos 100% claro cuán
complicada es la situación
de secretos o son secretos de estado y
él se lo llevó su defensa en ese sentido
ha sido con una media locura porque él
dice que como era el presidente él
decidía que era secreto y que no era
pero así no funciona el sistema en el
caso de hillary ya lo que usó fue un
correo electrónico no autorizado pero
nunca a sus trabajos documentos y peor
aún a tron se le está acusando de
obstruir la investigación
en curso porque negó haber tener los
documentos o alegó haberlos entregados
todo así que yo creo que es claramente
distinguible las dos situaciones pero
depende de efectivamente se podrá
convencer la ciudadanía de que eran
documentos verdaderamente secretos ese
es el reto que tiene el los demócratas y
la administración bueno usted lo
mencionaba hace un momento es un caso de
una gran magnitud que no tiene
precedentes en el departamento de
justicia a que se atiene esta cartera al
investigar a un ex presidente como don a
otro
bueno que del punto de vista político si
gana donald trump los procesos y si
llegamos hasta las próximas elecciones y
prevalencia donald trump tendrán la
furia de un presidente investigado así
que se le puede iraquí la vida no digo
literalmente probabilidad profesional a
mucha gente y tienen que asegurarse de
presentar un caso sólido para que
políticamente se mantenga general luis
pabón roca abogado y analista político
gracias por acompañarnos aquí en directo
américa
y vamos hasta israel porque decenas de
miles de solicitantes de asilo llegados
de áfrica sufren desprotección
institucional su situación irregular los
expone a pobres condiciones de trabajo y
de vida acompañadas de discriminación
frente a este vacío diversos grupos les
brindan asistencia y les ayudan en su
integración entre ellos la filial de un
club de fútbol que usa el deporte como
una herramienta este es un informe de
nuestro corresponsal federico cuevas
verena y yanira gómez muñoz
hace 7 años mucha llegó a israel huyendo
de la violencia en sudán en su travesía
de 16 días por el desierto del sinaí dos
de sus compañeros fueron asesinados al
cruzar la frontera las autoridades
israelíes lo encarcelaron seis meses en
s'agaró nim y un año en el centro de
detención a cielo abierto dejó lot antes
de ser liberado sin saber hebreo ni
tener permiso para trabajar o estudiar
no es que nos trataran de mala manera
pero fue muy difícil lidiar mentalmente
con la incertidumbre de no saber si te
van a enviar de vuelta a tu país o si te
van a dejar entrar desconfían de ti
entonces toda la ciudad que pide si
necesitas recibir no te la dan
es la realidad de más de 30.000
solicitantes de asilo en israel la
mayoría de sudaneses eritreos que sufren
un limbo legal solo desde hace semanas y
mucha pertenece al menos del 1% que ha
recibido el estatus de refugiado en su
integración el fútbol y un equipo fueron
claves estudiantes
nacida hace cinco años en la filial
israelí del club argentino estudiantes
de la plata mucho de un grupo de amigos
a un equipo multicultural que junto a
dos ongs asiste y reúne todo tipo de
ayuda a refugiados
nosotros hecho combatimos las barreras
de los estigmas y los refugiados bueno
se encuentra con problemáticas como por
ejemplo no tienen un seguro social no
tienen una posibilidad de estudiar en
cualquier lugar como si podría por
ejemplo un inmigrante o un israelí
estamos ahí en todo eso para ayudarlos a
que salgan adelante bajo las órdenes del
entrenador de este conjunto de israelíes
inmigrantes latinoamericanos y
solicitantes de asilo de áfrica se
entrena cada jueves para competir en una
liga amateur una vez que te pones acá en
el césped entras a jugar no importa si
hablas un idioma otro idioma en el
fútbol es como que su lenguaje aparte
se rompe esa barrera adentro de la
cancha o no se entiende por otros
sectores es un lenguaje el espíritu de
la filial pasa de boca en boca y cada
vez más solicitantes de asilo buscan
seguir los pasos de musas que frente al
vacío institucional de israel encontró
un hogar dentro y fuera de la cancha
hasta aquí directo américa edición
nocturna gracias por acompañarnos pero
no se desconecten que ya viene este era
con un nuevo capítulo de europa hoy
quédense con nosotros
[Música]